hi Tom how are you indefatigable also
dan are you are you I am great but you
know we're calling you with bad news
here with with Gronk down and out here
looks like for the rest of the year yeah
and in the statement the Patriots
basically acknowledging we're not
expecting him back in 2016 and Belichick
indicated you know they'll get more
information after the surgery is
complete and we'll update then but
there's no way he's coming back this
year it's a dubious claim the third time
his back has been opened up its his
ninth surgery since 2009 at 27 it is it
does cast a pall over things not just
football wise but you know as a player
and is what he represents kind of in the
week you look at his team without him
now how big of a difference is this
going to make pretty big and the reason
is we could talk about my calisthenics
and the flack that he'll pick up and the
facts of running games better but if you
just consider that Seattle game even
after he took a thunderous hit from real
promise down the stretch of that game he
made a 26-yard reception to put the
Patriots on the doorstep with 130 left
and then even with kam chancellor on him
the Patriots were still going to
Gronkowski on the game-ending place or
on the game-ending play so it shows how
much trust and faith they have in him so
they're still I would say more likely
than not to be the number one overall
seed in the best team in the AFC but
they have lost what they build their
offense around how did this injury
happen well he's got an impaired back
anyway and he got landed on against the
jets and that's what the Patriots and
the Gronkowski family released a
statement stating yesterday now there
was the need for that statement because
Vic Carucci who's a long time in
respective reporter tweeted that the
injury occurred against Seattle and I
talked to Vic yesterday I said well so
you're saying that
if it occurred against seattle that he
had a herniated disc previous to the
jets game and he was on the field
practicing last week and then taking the
field against the Jets as well with a
herniated disc which seems given the
care that they take both Gronkowski's
family and the Patriots and making sure
this guy's upright it seem like a
stretch to believe that they would
ascent to that what is the family on a
firefighter is it family upset with
anybody the Patriots hear the grunt
played this past week not yet
established I don't know why they would
be I mean he had what was called a
pulmonary contusion basically a UH an
organ bruise after the hit from rural
promise he took a week off he was
cleared to play medically and by
independent people so they put him on
the field but here then simply even
putting out a statement jointly with the
Gronkowski's is so far afield but it did
happen earlier last year it happened
after his knee injury so there is so
much care and feeding and maintenance of
not just Gronk Gronk inc and you know
gorda Gronkowski and it's a very well
educated group that they're dealing with
because all the kids have played in the
NFL and they understand that this is an
injury-prone kid whose livelihood and
ability to walk even um hinge on how he
is used on the football field and it's
not going away this has been a concern
for them since he was 20 years old do
you still consider New England their
favorite kinda kinda sorta that's I mean
that's hard hit hard-hitting reporting
right there give it to you straight so
will you look at him I mean do they
still have double chicken Brady so
that's the great equalizer I Oakland has
to close with games I believe at Kansas
City and at Denver yep and maybe at the
charges I got to check that but they
have a hellacious stretch I wouldn't be
surprised if Kansas City ends up winning
that division and I'm not looking at
Andy Reid and Alex missus that daunting
if they come to New England Patriots
hand
them pretty easily last year they're
better team heading toward the playoffs
than they were in 2015 and they were
just you know two-point conversion away
from going to slice that that team was
not hot that day and Belichick didn't
say x I'm sorry teleki say how's
everybody there you seem subdued I seem
some do Donna know why you don't see
yourself well this is a downer I'm
talking about Gronk he's done for the
year and like--see grunt play again be
nice to have the Patriots you know well
represented and that's that's alway
we're grilling steaks here during the
show everything's good fritzie's not
here everybody's in a good mood Tom I
just this is the victor so I have a Paul
yes I have to be a little sadder when
I'm talking to you I can't sound gleeful
if we're talking about Gronk yeah yeah
with that tone deaf on my part I'm a
little bit I I mean I'm just don't we
always whenever there's sad news you got
to come down a little bit there in sec
hello nobody tell what he does the sad
news like Chris Berman though did you
ever mesmerized by the way you could
tell avenging it in it dip it will you
have a mesmerized by the way you could
do that no I was not you I know but but
Chris will always after a sad story
he'll go will we'll be back after this
exactly right we'll be back after this
you josh it could be biblically there a
days uh yes so that's it everybody's in
a good mood no festive opened up
December great mood got steaks on the
grill and like you know I got we got
beer and bears chillin we're good and
then Grunk registered and everything
here's the interesting thing before you
know just one other aspect of this to
watch the Patriots have such great
control over drunk business-wise but
this could not have happened at a worse
time for him because they just picked up
the back end of the six year 54 million
dollar contract which pays him 4.25
million dollars in salary next year than
eight million and nine million way under
what everybody else is going to be
making very
easy to afford under the cap so watch
for that zip coming to a head and I
thought it was insensitive that you said
the back end of his deal the emphasis on
back well done tom well done thank you
no thanks thanks tongue yeah are we done
here yeah yeah I gotta cheer I gotta get
cheery now hi been subdued now I'm gonna
get cheered up a little bit here okay
alright okay alright thanks Thom that's
Tom Curren comcast sportsnet New England
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]